bonjour bienvenue à la semaine verte
l'impact de la remise à l'eau sur la
survie des poissons est un sujet tabou
chez les pêcheurs plusieurs préfèrent
penser que leurs proies survivre lorsque
relâchés ce qui n'est pas toujours le
cas
alors où le sort de certaines espèces
est préoccupant le ministère des forêts
de la faune et des parcs voudrait que
les pêcheurs revois certaines pratiques
[Musique]
la truite mouchetée c'est l'emblème de
la pêche récréative au québec c'est
aussi l'espèce la plus recherchée mais
ce poisson qu'on appelle aussi humble de
fontaine se porte mal dans les lacs
la mortalité est supérieure à la
capacité de renouvellement de l'espèce
chez 50 % des populations indigènes
richard conte ans est un ancien
professeur de techniques de pêche et
d'aménagement de la forme
aujourd'hui ils séjournent dans la zec
bas-saint-laurent le but de la partie de
pêche évaluer l'impact de la remise à
l'eau sur l'omble de fontaine la plus
fragile de toutes les espèces de truites
notre source pour la protéger ça
commence par une bonne remise elle comme
on le voit sur ces images relâcher les
poissons sans les blesser dans des
conditions qui favorisent leur survie
est un art que notre expert maîtrise
parfaitement
mais lors d'une autre journée pêche la
canicule est de la partie
l'eau du lac est de 24 degrés celsius
alors que la température idéale pour les
truites varie entre 12 et 15
les choses se déroulent moyens trochon
de ma fille tu remontes rebonds et aux
blessés vraiment pour chouette la
deuxième et à piqué parfait c'est bien
décrocher mais elle était même si j'ai
écouté incombe au maximum l'autre
vraiment trop chaud depuis la truite a
pas supporté le choc thermique
la diminution d'oxygène et ses excès de
truites est mort quand même la hausse de
température de l'eau entraînée par les
changements climatiques affectent
désormais l'omble de fontaine
sans compter les coupes forestières le
développement urbain et agricole et le
fait qu'on pêche trop de spécimens vu
l'état de la ressource
ce rabais c'est pas mal c'est sûr on
s'en rend compte de sujets c'est plus
dur
[Musique]
le problème c'est que les pêcheurs ne
sont pas tous conscients de l'urgence de
la situation
souvent ils pensent que si on arrête de
pêcher sur un plan d'eau ils ont juste
aller ailleurs puis le plan d'eau va se
rétablir lui même
par contre lorsqu'on observe un déclin
dans la qualité de la page
c'est que la déclaration très bien
entamé et à ce moment là même si on
arrête de pêcher c'est très difficile de
rétablir l'équilibré de retrouver une
qualité page
pour tenter de sauver l'espèce le
ministère des forêts de la faune et des
parcs veut améliorer le taux de survie à
la remise à l'eau mais pour ça il faut
changer les habitudes des pêcheurs la
majorité utilise encore l'hameçon hengy
auquel est accroché un ver de terre
or avec cette dame sont de 35 à 50 % des
truites mouchetées meurt quelques heures
après avoir été remise à l'eau c'est 1,6
million d'ombles de fontaine par année
dans la zec bas saint laurent
le problème est bien connu l'ombre de
fontaine est sensible aux manipulations
puis le fait qu'à laval profondément
l'ailé les proies naturelles les
appoints naturel ben souvent c'est eric
planes et que si on en venait à l'oa
vont mourir de toute façon donc sa
fausse également nos quotas
d'exploitation
le problème c'est comme si un truc c'est
nier pour inculper dahmane plusieurs que
j'ai vu et qui ont mis en mettant à
l'eau puis ça fait ça c'est un respect
total pour stopper le déclin québec
demandent maintenant aux pêcheurs
d'utiliser des leurres artificiels moins
dommageable que les vers de terre
et pour ceux qui souhaitent conserver
les appâts naturels
on conseille des hameçons circulaire
dont on a écrasé lardillon même si le
maire de taabo être avalé profondément
la forme de la maison va faire en sorte
qu'il ne s'accrochera pas dans
l'oesophage dans l'estomac et voient
plutôt venir se loger au niveau de la
mâchoire
ce qui vaut grandement limiter la
gravité des blessures est aussi facilité
de l'aide décrochage est donc
l'exposition à l'air mais puisque le
sort de la truite mouchetée est
préoccupant pourquoi ne pas simplement
interdire la remise à l'eau de cette
espèce si fragile d'interdire la remise
à l'eau c'est une option qui a été
envisagé et considéra que c'est une
modalité qui était moins bien reçus chez
les pêcheurs
on a décidé de le choisir autre chose
le ministère des forêts de la faune et
des parcs a donc abaissé le quota de
prises quotidiennes qui est passé de 15
à 10 dans la plupart des secteurs
personnellement j'ai pris ça comme une
grande victoire pour la ressource parce
que j'étais étudiant au cégep en 85 86
on voyait déjà des problèmes
on ne veut ni stocks diminuer diminué
diminué et il est atteint je pense qu'il
y était vraiment talent pour le saumon
de l'atlantique aussi les quotas ont été
abaissées
depuis 50 ans on assiste à un déclin
dans la plupart des régions de la
province
le nombre de saumons qui retourne en
rivière est en deçà du seuil requis pour
assurer la survie de l'espèce
québec limite donc les captures un seul
grand saumon par saison sur les rivières
qui atteignent un nombre suffisant de
géniteurs pour les petits saumons ces
deux par jour maximum
la remise à l'eau est donc en plein
essor ellis au money comme daniel
lavallée déteste quand leurs efforts de
conservation sont contrecarrés en 2019
ils pêchent au saguenay en compagnie
d'un ami lorsque sont mortes à l'hameçon
il réussit à le prendre
il se fait photographier avec sa prise
moi je compte jusqu'à 5,5 ce donneur
daloa pressent leurs e mails poissons à
l'eau puis normalement tout va bien mais
cette fois les choses dérapent sous les
yeux de son ami qui fit natale
[Applaudissements]
ils y arrivent pour leur arracher la
mire de qui j'étais mais fumer puis en
relâchant le poisson on voit le poisson
partir mais le ventre en l'air sur le
dos le g20 il ya quelque chose qui
marche pas bien évidemment je suis prêt
mais nous ça a pris dix minutes avant
que le poisson que c'est viable à
soutenir emballant il est allé dans le
fond de la rivière pendant il reste au
même endroit pendant 15 minutes 10
minutes plus moment donné on ne fait
partie selon une estimation du ministère
des forêts de la faune et des parcs
seulement 7% des sceaux m'empêcher au
québec morts lorsqu'ils sont remis à
l'eau
dans la province le saumon est pêché
uniquement à la mouche avec des apports
artificiel ils sont avalés beaucoup
moins profondément que les vers de terre
ce qui cause moins de blessures aux
poissons mais cette portion de mortalité
c'est uniquement lorsque toutes les
bonnes pratiques sont respectés limiter
la durée du combat ne pas traîner le
saumon sur la berge et surtout ne pas
brandir le poisson hors de l'eau
les études démontrent clairement que de
garder un saumon pendant plusieurs
secondes en dehors de l'eau va réduire
considérablement ses chances de survie
donc on peut prendre une magnifique
photo en gardant le poisson dans l'eau
c'est encore mieux
du coup deux raisons l'égard d'un saumon
pendant 10 15 secondes en dehors de nous
c'est en théorie la réalité c'est que la
fameuse photo trophée encore la cote
auprès des pêcheurs la personne n'a ri
puis prince charmant sur un menu qui le
dalo qui leur revient temps des photos
le reste est pas encore finie l'on veut
faire une photo de photos trois photos
d'un bandeau de bolat est à bord des
organes qui se promènent à l'intérieur
lorsque - personnage prend les photos
sont ici sur la rivière rimouski dans la
zec saumon la température de l'eau
atteint parfois 27 degrés celsius or on
sait que passer 20 degrés le taux de
mortalité de saumon remis à l'eau
augmente considérablement
ble ment québec s'est demandé si le
succès reproducteur des saumons gracié
pouvait lui aussi être influencés par la
température de l'eau parce qu'un second
qui est dépensé beaucoup d'énergie à
lutter contre un pêcheur peu apprécié à
récupérer du stress physiologique et ses
lieux cause est d'être capable
d'atteindre les meilleurs sites de
reproduction est ce qu'il va être
capable de trouver et de défendre deux
réunis de façon efficace votre 7 capable
d'aller trouver les partenaires et
sexuelle qui lui faut pour répondre à
ces questions
cet étudiant du département de biologie
de l'université laval à prélever les
séquences d'adn et n des saumons
remonter dans la passe migratoire de la
rivière rimouski qu en 2018
j'ai construit une espèce de structure
qui me permettait de les échantillonnés
de façon sécuritaire
on pouvait avoir des montaisons qui
allait jusqu'à 30 secondes donc si ce
monde là il y attendre dans mon
dispositif qui peut autant que si je n
ai qu une rivière donc tu devais
travailler rapidement efficacement et
les gardiens situent les pêcheurs locaux
ont participé à l'expérience cette année
là chaque fois qu'on capture est un
savant qu on leur mettait à l'eau devait
faire un point sonne un poinçon dans son
immense joie a disparu depuis leur métal
ou parce que vous ne se faisait pas
génétique avec ça
l'année suivante raphaël bouchard a
prélevé des alevins pour vérifier leur
assignation parental
les résultats préliminaires du chercheur
indique que la température de l'eau
n'affecte pas la reproduction du saumon
mais les femelles remise à l'eau ont 30%
moins de chances de se reproduire que
celles qui n'ont jamais été pêché remise
à l'eau venir puiser dans les réserves
d'énergie que le saumon accumulée lors
de son séjour en main lorsqu'à la remise
à l'eau prend beaucoup de torts
lorsqu'elle est mal effectué sa veut
consommer plus d'énergie qui était
exclusivement réservée pour la
reproduction
le ministère des forêts de la faune et
des parcs en prend bonne note
le temps d'observer de façon générale un
impact sur le succès reproducteur
ça nous amène à nous questionner par
rapport au choix de gestion mais je
dirais quand même d'une manière ou d'une
autre ce monde qui est remis à l'eau
beaucoup plus de chance d'aborder
descendants que le poisson qui est placé
dans une glacière
l'espèce est menacée je crois pas que
c'est la cause de ce qui se passe en
rivière en ce moment on va beaucoup
faire de notre mieux dans nos vidéos
c'est par la suite y reviendrons on y
prie avec un problème entier
en amérique du nord c'est en mer que la
plupart des saumons de l'atlantique
meurent au cours du voyage qui les mène
au groënland et changement climatique et
autres bouleversements sont en cause des
facteurs sur lesquels les pêcheurs
locaux n'ont aucune prise
de là l'importance de redoubler
d'efforts pour protéger les rares
adultes qui reviennent en rivière chaque
année